Wesley a rather tame and comfortable
there at the office but when he saw the
Catalan and you remembered what happened
to Ray yesterday were you a bit worried
at any point yeah and I thought that he
fabi's been hanging out also with
Gregory operand
uh so I figured I'd play something else
I thought he might go for D4 considering
that they're working together and uh
yeah I think we got an interesting game
uh thought we played this line very
quickly this bishop B3 thing he's
following uh uh cram next game also
um
Richard report against mvl from a few
months ago last year were you aware of
this idea of Bishop to B3 you were
trying to re remember yourself your
analysis yeah I never expected this to
show up over the board like uh here
white wants to play quick E4 I mean I
could play Knight C6 but I didn't really
you know 936 Castle B5 then we need to
we need two and it's a completely
different line yeah but our Venture I
mean Fabia some ideas
but I thought this line was pretty
harmless if black knows what he's doing
with C5 early on B5 C5 and 84 yeah yeah
and and here the critical line I guess
it's Bishop B7 or Knight D7 but I wasn't
very familiar with Knight D7 so I
thought I played Bishop D6
is this something that you prepared at
home or you heard that it works or yeah
I prepared no I prepared after Castle
Bishop B7
so so I prepared with the white can
Castle we should be serving castle and
now Bishop is now Bishop D6 so this is
uh the usual Theory yeah but I guess
Bishop B7 Fabi had prepared E5 so I
thought I'd play Bishop D6 first huh D5
yeah bb7 E5
and it's very tricky like he told me
after game the after Bishop B7 E5 Knight
fd7
Bishop takes not not Castle apparently
97. yeah after Bishop E6 black cannot
take on E6 finally Knight E6 is just
much much better for white yeah although
it wasn't that clear to me during the
game but that's why I played Bishop D6
just to avoid all this and
and it did seem like this move surprised
him he made him pause
yeah it's not the more suggested by an
engines and modern Chef these days we
kind of have to as the one would say
play sometimes some Sidelines yeah yeah
because if they just keep following the
mainline clearpoint knows it very well
too but not partly it's a solid movement
were you worried about any any moves at
this point I think the engine was saying
Queen to E2 yeah Fabi was calculating we
need to for a long time that's the best
move Bishop to E5 but still it was very
complicated
seven ah and then castle castle Bishop
Bishop B7 Castle oh
this position
this position in your calculation yeah
it looks playable for black
but I did I don't like so instead of
Castle move 13 and I guess Bishop A3
seems a bit dangerous yes yes definitely
dangerous so it's it's very tricky
amazing the pawn Castle you still have
to hide your king somehow not easy but
dangerous for both sides yes at least I
win a pawn yes yes so but I got an
interesting game I think there's one
Bishop B7 I'm back to my preparation
one thing that he could have done maybe
was to take on E6 did you spot this one
yeah just remember it's harmless for
black women so after it takes today
Queen D6 yeah I wasn't sure G8 or Knight
did this
um yeah I was going to play Rook G8
Queen E6
ah and then you go for an end game huh
oh heavy queen of five or queen it's
yeah
with deep engines it would end up in a
draw at this point yeah white get the
13. go for this now yeah it'll be
interesting too but I remember E1 was
what I like Bishop E5 and now Bishop B3
Bishop to E3 yeah Knight C6 takes takes
probably black is fine here oh although
it's slightly worse but what he play in
the game was interesting like this five
like I didn't expect this at all
night bd7 yeah it's probably nothing for
white now one and you defend it
accurately and in fact it felt like at
some point well it might even have been
better after Knight fd7 did you spot
this movie yeah try this move thinking
about this for a long time but then I
got really low on the clock and I was
thinking at what this move for 15 20
minutes and he decided to simplify the
position yeah decided not to because I
wasn't sure after Knight C3 Queen F6
yeah my first intention is why it's
ambitious Bishop g3965 Queen D6
like he did three have likes just much
better here
seems like it yeah but yeah if you don't
have the engine open it's not that easy
to assess this one yeah
maybe a move 17 Bishop E5
uh Knight takes I would like also better
okay yeah yeah I should have played
knife D7 but definitely not not easy too
for sure yeah well Venture facts better
or worse and decided to I looked at my
clock on the side that they just take
the pot Wesley you're you're doing it
all tomorrow with the white pieces are
you going to try to pressure take uh any
extra risks or are you okay with a
potential playoff
uh
uh well it's hard to say I mean I
just want to play some good chess you
know like
try to make use of my chances they come
you know after I put pressure if I can
but at the same time also it's still
very tired from my certain burden so
it's hard to say what the right decision
is but it's nice to play again so I'm
the defending Champion absolutely nice
for you but nice for us as well and for
the fans around the world we're
definitely enjoying this huge Clash
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
uh Wesley because you had such an easy
day at the office I'm going to have to
put you to work for just a second before
we let you go taking a look at the
elimination bracket game between Sam
sevillan and Lavon aronium give us your
quick uh need your
um
tell me who you like and why in this
game uh well I I don't like fan because
he has to win but I think that he that
he has a very good position right I mean
it could be wrong but Bishop Jitter and
H5 is coming
um
maybe black of the plane Knight C5 I
guess and then Knight A4
okay I don't know it seems that white
has
why there's some chances not much but
definitely something so especially in a
must win situation yeah probably yeah
it's the best I need to know for I mean
if time is okay
he's got the dark for control but Knight
C5
followed by Rook d8 or Knight A4 seems a
bit annoying to me so
uh it seems are you in time so Bishop to
G3
5 H5 oh it's black
then that's problematic yeah yeah uh
Knight A4 King C2
maybe even Rook d8 to start off with
yeah
C3 Rook D3 is coming Rook d8
yeah now that I see this seems like
black is not risking anything
at all because also the epon is double
basically it just limits White's Bishop
yeah
all right thank you uh Wesley and good
luck tomorrow uh nice to have you in the
commentary Booth with us
absolutely uh Ray Robson